they can see you at lunch huh see you
later
oh
yes why is Ted lasso so great and how
can you be more like him let's take a
look at exactly how Apple TV pluses hit
show Ted lasso makes you feel so good
and how you can be just like Ted the
answer might actually surprise you first
of all in my book Ted lasso is the
definition of a feel-good show it has an
absolutely incredible attention to tone
always leaving me in a cheery mood and
it does this while still playing on a
lot of heavy subjects such as depression
divorce and death refresher for those of
you that don't remember Ted lasso is the
story of an American football coach who
goes to England to coach a Premier
League soccer team when he has
absolutely zero knowledge about the
sport what he does have though is an
incredibly positive outlook on life and
probably one of the best coaching
mentalities I've ever seen when he
arrives in England basically everyone
hates him and thinks he's going to get
the team relegated or demoted to a lower
league in the midst of all that hate
though Ted stays positive and this got
me thinking how can I be more like Ted
lasso well first of all you have to
think like a goldfish you know what the
happiest animal on earth is goldfish
you know why
no got a 10 second memory be a goldfish
Sam this idea of being like a goldfish
doesn't apply just to the players but to
Ted as well he never lets people's
negativity or hateful actions stand in
the way of him developing close
connections with the very same people
who want him gone in this aspect at
least I think we should all be like
goldfish another seemingly small but
really important way to be more like Ted
is to tell people you appreciate them
doing so goes such a long way you got
this hey
and Rebecca's grateful for all your hard
work thanks
thank you although this clip was
obviously used for comedic effect it
does show just how far Ted is willing to
go to show his appreciation the biggest
way to be like Ted lasso though is to
find ways to help people become the best
versions of themselves for me success is
not about the wins and losses it's about
helping these young fellows be the best
versions of themselves on and off the
field even if you're not a coach a
teacher or a manager you can still focus
on becoming the best version of yourself
this is something Ted struggles with
throughout the series but he continues
to embody this message through his
infectious positivity and his ability to
see the good in everyone in a world
where negativity and cynicism seem to be
the norm Ted lasso is a refreshing
change of pace the show doesn't stray
away from negative topics though even
engaging in some pretty heavy themes
such as depression divorce and death for
example we get a close look into Ted's
personal life as he struggles with his
divorce having to find his own place all
the way on the opposite side of the
world he gives insight into his past
struggles with marriage counseling and
even tells the story of how his dad died
when he was just 16 years old it's these
kinds of closer more intimate moments
that makes Ted lasso so special and
helps the show to stand apart from the
crowd and stand apart it has receiving
11 Emmy Awards and 40 nominations in its
first two seasons alone while the humor
and Ted last also is certainly a
highlight it's the show's heartfelt
moments that really make it stand out
for moments of Triumph to moments of
sadness the show isn't afraid to pull at
our heartstrings but what's great about
these moments is that they never feel
cheap or forced they're earned through
the relationships the characters build
and the journeys they find themselves on
one of the main reasons why Ted lasso is
so great is its exceptional character
development each character is unique and
brings something different to the table
from the optimistic and Charming Ted
lasso to the stubborn and hard-headed
Roy Kent we see each character evolve
and grow throughout the series this
makes the characters feel real and
relatable which is one of the reasons
why the audience connects with them on
such a deep level take Jamie tart for
example he goes from a spoiled bratty
yet incredibly gifted player to a team
Advocate and close friend to many
characters on the show what amazes me
though is not that the show has
characters that can change as much as
Jaime but rather that it makes me
believe that this could actually happen
in real life if you haven't seen the
show then I won't spoil Nate's character
development but it's even more drastic
than Jamie's and still believable which
is amazing now why does the show always
seem to make me smile because it makes
me feel good it's gotten to the point
where just seeing a picture of Jason
Sudeikis flushes my brain with dopamine
and a lot of this comes down to the
show's humor the series is absolutely
hilarious and has plenty of laugh out
loud moments but what makes it even
better is that the humor never comes at
the expense of the characters instead
it's used to bring the characters
together and to create a sense of
camaraderie amongst them the show always
lifts people up and never puts them down
it shows how everyone has something
special about them that can have its
very own Focus most of all though the
show and Ted lasso are humble they put
their egos aside to focus on what truly
matters shoes Ted's shoe game is on
point they even have their own Instagram
I mean look at these bad boys and these
okay bye
foreign